welcome to this video playing Yvonne
yeah let's key prandi sister real name
maybe okay let's try this line again all
right do you think it it is an
interesting alternative to the main
lines open I what such King be one now
23 mmmm yeah you see that I don't really
know it in any big big detail king be
one is very useful anyway okay
hmm don't know every age for wasn't the
brightest idea yeah I can take here but
if he takes with the pawn this will be
quite nice for black hmm yeah but do I
want to retreat the bishop yep I can at
least I can go to see one now not that
this is totally great but ok h4 wasn't a
very very fortunate move probably okay
what about g4 year g4 is got 'if i am
but if it would be interesting otherwise
g4 Knight takes Queen g7 is quite nice
so he cannot take on ji ho Bertie 5 is a
good move
Jim
Luke g 1 and g for a black might cast a
long if possible maybe I should just
voluntarily retreat the Queen that's not
doing anything ready anyway an ID format
been optioned 94 than f 3g form
yeah one important point is that this
age 6 move while being a bit annoying at
the time has some distinct disadvantage
of course if you canceled short g45 is
really hitting hard so he must be a very
cautious about that can be form but he
can actually play before be 496 just
Queen 26 hmm okay yeah I can just take
with the Queen attic this is not a very
very bright game here but I'm playing
Jim you cannot really make a piece
sacrifice out of it like this and 95
this is totally totally unsound
yeah well nitey to Queenie for I mean
after that it's even tough to not
exchange Queens yeah come on it is it is
totally unsound but this is still a
better chance than then playing them
with a central pawn down and no play
whatsoever g45 can can try that the
problem is that i have simply don't
elect pieces here very often you can
sacrifice a piece like that if there are
more more pieces left then you need some
pieces to actually check mate like with
and at the moment this is not a parent
what pieces I should to the checkmate in
booth as so many are traded okay we had
to go now I can go here g6 Queen f4
cannot take on d5 I think because of
Queenie form now maybe you can actually
maybe you can as night b6 and maybe even
not see through check but okay I don't
have any big alternative here if I get
in b3 Bishop b2 who this might might
become sufficiently murky
okay and now we can obviously take what
a game ok Knight c3 check oh my god yeah
it's I know it's not very difficult
maybe maybe I can still do that check
yeah it's hanging on on h8 totally
unintended everything but yeah this is a
shame be three was really idiotic just
when I was about to get a bit of
compensation I really had some
compensation they're not enough but but
it was starting to to get to get
something time money yeah I know I know
absolutely yeah kk 1 i'll continue a
couple of moves but it's us of course
totally lost
ya can even play it for him check yeah
okay white resigned yeah one one of
those early morning games you really
shouldn't play yeah okay well here and
this was just totally totally faulty all
this yeah I mean here I need to do
something else it's it's not great
anyway but yeah the problem is if we
start right here he played age 60 k h6
taking is not good because of that this
just gives black an excellent position
this is this is just just very nice for
black so the capture is super young so I
retreated and here well this is just
just giving away material then don't
sacrifice i'm i'm losing the pawn and i
cannot even I don't have a queen move
really to avoid the Queen trade as
there's always a society I can't play
this but what is that I don't have
anything here so this is why I sacrifice
the peace and yeah moves like like g6
actually gave me some hope but b3 is
totally your take of course I just
overlooked this so yeah the thing is if
I go something like this I mean okay
objectively speaking black should win
but this is this is already a bit murky
I really think so in a blitz game
because in this g6 ladies there is some
some disharmony in black scammed if I
get the bishop to the long diagonal then
this isn't totally clear something like
here rupee
and then I'm not sure maybe the d5 pawn
is really hanging now yeah something
like that I mean there's it's tough to
analyze it's just still a practical
chance but yeah this was totally brain
dead okay I could have resigned but okay
in just a couple of the move plate yeah
not not one of the brightest games okay
thanks for watching